overnight dozens of Palestinians have
been killed in Israeli air strikes
Across The besieged Enclave in the
southern city of Kanan yunes a strike on
a popular Cafe there killed 12 people
displaced Palestinians had gathered
there to use its working generator
separately an Israeli air strike also in
carun on a house killed two women and an
8-year-old child in central Gaza an
Israeli air raid on a shopping plaza
killed nine people and wounded dozens of
others as you can see a fire engulfed
the market in the al- nerat refugee camp
destroying several stores let's bring in
a Palestinian journalist hany abua he
joins us now from Kan yunas in the Gaza
Strip Kan we know the bombardment has
been intensifying there in kanun can you
tell us what you've been seeing and
hearing yes we're uh the past 24 hours
has been really intense for Palestinians
living in the northern part and the
southern part of the Gaza trip under
Mass bombardment uh this is the part in
which the Israeli military ordered
Palestinian from the north and Gaza to
evacuate to to only find them themselves
under Mass bombardment so late hours of
last night at about
11:00 uh a busy a busy street in the in
theat refugee camp uh this street is is
a thriving market for uh the people of
doat camp and because of the people who
evacuate to that area it became more
busy and it crowded people were lining
up at one of the uh popular food
restaurants buying their dinner were was
targeted uh leaving tens of casualties
the initial reports talk about more than
10 were killed at the spot one of those
c one of those victims is a Dutch
Nationals a woman carrying the Dutch
nationality a killed in the attack on a
noat market in noat Camp in the middle
areas of the Gaza Strip it's interesting
to know that this lady uh since the
beginning of of this air stri campaign
uh has been going uh uh forth and back
to the RAF Crossing trying to leave uh
but could not her last attempt was
yesterday when the humanitarian Convoy
was allowed uh to enter the Palestinian
side but she could not make it out of
Gaza and later on that night she was
killed in the attack another major
attack took place in the city of KH
yunes a very crowded uh Cafe and the
reason uh uh people uh uh went to that
Cafe it's because it had a little bit of
electricity a small power generator so
what everybody thought that they could
charge their phones get their power
Banks full or get a little bit of
Internet just to see what's going on as
people have been blacked out for the
past 15 days of these of these uh
miserable events uh honey you mentioned
the humanitarian Convoy there we know
that these 28 trucks made it into the
Gaza Strip it's obviously nowhere near
enough but it's hopefully a start do we
know where these supplies have now ended
up okay well we just learned half an
hour ago that those 20 trucks who were
allowed into the Gaza Strip are still
outside the Palestinian gate just a few
meters away from the Palestinian Gates
and were not allow to move away from the
RAF Crossing so they are still there and
now the intention the plan was these 20
trucks uh would move from the RAF
Crossing enter Gaza all the way to D
City to a designated United Nations
Warehouse uh it's uh important to
mention that these humanitarian Aid are
only intended for the southern part of
the Gaza Strip none of these
humanitarian Aid is going to the
northern part or Gaza governor and it's
also uh important to point out that
these are only medical supplies and food
supplies there's no there's no fuel
supplies in this humanitarian convo
which is which makes it very difficult
for hospitals to to sustain themsel and
operate given the necessary Health
Services needed for the large influx of
casualties in in the Gaza Strip honey
abua they're a Palestinian journalist
with the latest forest from the ground
in the Gaza Strip and just recapping
there honey you were saying that that
Aid Convoy has not actually made it to
its destination and is rather stuck near
Rafa still thank you so much we'll be
bringing you more on that as we get it
here on Al
jazer